was a to buy something lewd but that was
not difficult as there was a gigantic
hand tight the like huh bought like I
think like half of the source was just
like 18 so I'm like I'm like this is big
bro mode what what lewd thing can i buy
that's really cheap and can keep me on
budget so join altar John old horse
I just okay I need I was I was more
focused on fine finding a cover which
wouldn't get us easily like which just
wouldn't get this video off the what am
I too much do you monetize yeah that's
big brain youtuber boy but I did buy one
more okay but I just checked it before
we start recording I don't think maybe
mood on just put like a huge black
screen over whatever God brings out so I
bought docume Cara hanging up on the
wall that was like the intent we're not
gonna be able to use this because I was
like I need to buy dakimakura me survive
so I bought the cheapest one I could
find
and like it was in it was in the section
where there weren't many like the
dakimakura is one allude there were some
ludes there were some one and they're
all like covered up with this I couldn't
I couldn't tell how loot the dark matter
is were I just chose the cheapest one oh
wow black all of that out like all of
this they sell that this wasn't this
wasn't even in the hentai section okay
can I ask no can I ask because you got
the cheapest one how much was that
forty bucks and that's the cheapest
forty bucks
that's the cheapest the cheapest one bro
I got like a sans one at home that was
like a tenner
don't ask why